we've got a bombshell today and it has
absolutely nothing to do with Donald
Trump's ties to Russia through Vladimir
Putin or Donald Trump ties to Russia
through his associates hiding meetings
that they've had with Russian diplomats
this is a totally new and different and
very disturbing possible connection to
Russia for Donald Trump
it appears that Donald Trump was part of
a fraud and money laundering operation
connected to Russia we did a story back
on March 30th about Donald Trump
different connections to organized crime
and there has been a major development
to one of the aspects of that story so
I'll remind you back in March on March
2nd of the year 2000 early in the
morning New York City is the scene 100
federal agents swooped in and arrests 11
people connected to the Russian and
italian-american mafias and they had
been under investigation for fraud a 40
million-dollar scheme and these Russian
and Italian American mobsters were
operating what's called a pump and dump
scheme this is when you buy typically
cheap stocks penny stock stocks under $5
a share really worthless companies you
then make a concerted effort to promote
those stocks so that people will start
buying them and drive up the price and
again you can only really do that
effectively with low value stocks then
you sell the shares because again
they're not really worth anything and
then ultimately people figure out what's
going on and the share price crashes but
you've made out with a lot of money
tons of victims many people lost their
savings their retirement money everybody
who was arrested initially in the year
2000 was found guilty and sentenced
except for one man named Felix Seder a
Russian American mobster who was
sentenced only 10 years later with only
a small fine and a slap on the wrist
why such a light punishment well he was
working as an informant for the FBI and
the CIA and as I told you a few months
ago during these 10 years
Felix aider was also doing business with
a guy named Donald J Trump who happened
to now be the President of the United
States Trump took on Seder as a senior
adviser for the Trump Organization they
tried to build a hotel tower
might have been condos in Phoenix
Arizona didn't pan out they did build a
tower in Fort Lauderdale Florida which
has since been foreclosed upon and
together they built the Trump Soho Hotel
in lower Manhattan so Trump is clearly a
pretty close business partner with a
Russian mobster who was convicted for
participating in a 40 million dollar
fraud and money laundering scheme but
all of that everything I've told you so
far especially you pad if you're taking
notes over there we knew everything I've
told you so far here's what's new about
all of this Bloomberg is now reporting
that while Trump and SATA were working
together from 2002 to 2011 Sater was
still actively involved in illegal
activities according to a new lawsuit
one of Saders employees from when he was
working for Trump is named jody kriss
chris is now suing seder saying that
different european governments and
officials were secretly funneling money
into donald trump's real estate projects
and that seder was laundering that money
in offshore bank accounts the lawsuit
also says that seder was skimming money
from the operation and dodging taxes and
cheating Chris out of millions of
dollars which is why he's now suing him
when working for seder chris said seder
would encourage him to only take
investment money from people and
companies that were close to Vladimir
Putin Trump knew he was working with a
Russian mobster convicted of fraud and
money laundering the question though is
did Trump know that his projects were
funneling money from sources close to
Putin and again pat no sketchy
connections between Donald Trump and
burundi no unexplained connections from
Donald Trump and his associates to the
Ivory Coast no undisclosed meetings with
diplomats from Liechtenstein it's Russia
time and again well you know when the
Washington Post reported that Trump was
personally under investigation for
obstruction of justice by the Special
Counsel robert muller right what got
left unnoticed and really didn't grab
the headlines was that Trump associates
were under investigation for financial
crimes that's what are you including
financial crimes things like fraud money
laundering that's right and Jared
Kushner's business dealings now also
under scrutiny
so yes you are absolutely right about
that this could be this could be an
entire new front if there were no Russia
scandal already this is a whole new
story that now has opened up and we're
going to follow up on it